how about that that's great
good okay sorry for that yeah so again
thanks thanks for uh
inviting me to participate in this i
look forward to uh learning
a lot myself and i hope the few remarks
i have here will
help orient you towards the issues in
contact tracing
that i see and in particular relevant to
the themes of this conference
algorithm design law and policy
law and policy are not my areas of
expertise but i will make a few remarks
at the end about those particular issues
the outline for the talk
i'm going to have one page on
disambiguation because pact is ambiguous
and then talk about contact tracing both
manual and digital
and then talk about one of the key
technical problems with
digital contact tracing which is
measuring distance with smartphones
talk something about privacy and
integration with public health
and then one of the key issues uh for
getting these things to be
useful is having a widespread adoption
talking about that
talk a little bit about effectiveness of
the contact racing apps what does it
mean to
have effectiveness how do we think about
that talk about some law and policy
issues and then conclude
i'll be happy to take questions i guess
we have a question uh session after uh
helen talks so
but thanks again for inviting me to
participate uh so the disambiguation
page
uh the project at mit that i most
involved is packed
and uh that stands for private automated
contact tracing we have a
web page on that which you're invited to
look at pack.mit.edu
but there is also the that's packed east
coast and there's also a west coast pact
and we've had some discussions about
which of us should change our name and
we decided neither of us should because
we do
enough different things although they
are closely related so anyway when i say
packed i mean packed east
but just be aware that there's a packed
west so what is manual contact tracing
so i'm trying to fight a pandemic like
this uh
manual contact tracing works by as
follows when a person
which is usually called the index case
the first the
the person that's uh found to be
positive uh with a test of
pcr tests say then you want to find all
of the
or most anyway of the people that he may
have exposed those are called contacts
that's called contact tracing and that's
traditionally been a manual process
by starting off with once the person
test positive
having an interview with a disease
investigator
sometimes called or a contact tracer and
then once the index case lists people
that he may have been close to over the
last
period of infectiousness which could be
up to a couple of weeks maybe
they start calling the contacts and uh
trying to find out if they're showing
symptoms uh advising them to get a test
maybe maybe uh
depending on the situation advising them
to quarantine themselves and so on so
that that's where the interventions
start
so the contact tracing is intended to
prevent the spread of the disease
it doesn't help the index case because
they've already tested positive
and the contacts uh you know are
sequestered if they've already got it
so it's not helping them either but it
may help their family or other people
that they contact
so this allows contacts to be
quarantined symptom checked and tested
and it's a powerful method for
flattening the curve it's been used in
many different pandemics going way back
much before technology
came to the play here and it helps
remove infectious people from
circulation that's the key point you
stop the spread of the disease
by having infectious people not
circulating in the general population
and not infecting other people
so the limitations of this are speed it
has to be done quickly to prevent
infected people from walking around
compliance
people may not pick up the phone to talk
to the contact tracer
or they may not give truthful answers or
they may
you know for various reasons and they
may not remember some of the people they
were near they were on the bus and the
people sitting near them on the bus so
they just don't know who they were so uh
manual contact tracing has its
limitations uh
now that we have smartphones and
everybody's carrying a smartphone a lot
of people are carrying smartphones
around we can
try applying technology to make this
process a better one so my own
involvement in this
came about when i was teaching with yael
kalai who many of you i'm sure know
uh last spring a security course and we
talked about the apple find my protocol
which is designed to help you find
a lost phone this is a very clever
protocol designed by apple
and it uses apple devices
and bluetooth technology to help sense
proximity between
pairs of such devices say two phones and
the phone broadcast values these values
change frequently for privacy protection
so you can't just say
i've heard this person's phone because i
know what they're broadcasting it
changes every few minutes
and uh there's lots of other protections
for privacy this is a very clever
protocol where apple itself does not
know
which phones were near other phones
there's a public database nonetheless
that apple maintains which allows the
owner to find out where the last the
phone was last seen
and that location information was
encrypted with a public key of the phone
that was
lost uh the last time it was seen or
heard
so the patch protocol is similar to that
the idea is you know well if you can use
bluetooth to measure proximity for this
kind of application why not for
covet 19 contact tracing so we can have
the phone broadcast
chirps that change every so often for
the same kind of privacy issues
and then other phones can listen in and
remember which chirps they heard
if the owner tests positive uh for the
disease then he can upload to
a public database the seeds the
cryptographic seeds for generating those
chirps
which is basically posting all the
chirps he broadcast
and others can then download that
database
and check in a decentralized manner if
they've heard chirps of infected people
so they determine on their phone
themselves whether they might have been
infected
there's no essential no computation done
at the central database
to identify the potentially affected
people it's done locally in a
decentralized manner
is one again one of the privacy features
of such protocols
there are many variants on these ideas
uh dp3t and switzerland tcm
and other others uh are you know have
developed protocols and lots of
academic literature evolving on this
stuff but these are the main
features where the phones are
broadcasting chirps other phones maybe
if near enough recording them and then
checking later
to see if the infected person has posted
what chirps you broadcast after that
infected person
has tested to be uh positive there's
lots of countries rolling out such apps
at the moment so that's the main idea of
digital
contact racing
we formed a team at mit sent first and
then expanding out from that
to look at these issues and these
possibilities
formed in early march on the mit campus
myself on danny weitz the leads are
myself and danny weinstein
danny uh was at the white house with
obama and uh
is co-leading this along with mark
zissman and israel saw women from
lincoln lab he's out there and louis dr
louise ivers from
harvard uh mgh uh so we've been
working together to lead it but it's a
big project um
and there are many organizations now
represented in this mit
they can lab of course fgh but the
weissman institute bu brown ibm
carnegie mellon uh mitre northeastern
whatever
it's a big long list of organizations
that
are all participating together very open
collaboration we're all trying to
have some positive public health impact
and we're not worried about
academic credit not sure i think other
things like that it's mostly
trying to what are the good ideas what
works how can we make this happen
more than a hundred people involved uh
locally in boston um
and we're particularly strong on what we
call layer one which is the bluetooth
ranging thing how far away are the two
phones from each other because that's
one of the challenging
questions as i'll talk about but we have
strong relationships with other teams
uh apple and google in particular uh is
helping with some of the foundational
implementations
other vendors jurisdictions uh various
states or cities or
universities even public health
authorities in various places so
uh a lot of people talking with each
other trying to figure out how to make
this
technology work and our role is
primarily as a technology as
evaluator and advisor we're not
developing apps
although we might help develop protocols
that go into the apps
we're most interested in trying to help
good things happen by coordinating and
evaluating and
discussing with people rather than
taking credit for this thing this is you
know
what we invented or whatever it doesn't
matter who invented it we're trying to
save some lives here
so one of the key technical questions um
too close for too long accuracy
measuring distance and time time is
pretty easy so distance is the challenge
the cdc
says too close for too long should be
less than six feet for more than 15
minutes if you're
within six feet of someone for more than
15 minutes you've got
that that's a too close for too long
event and you may have been
infected and you need to get tested or
have some other intervention applied
and so it's the six feet measurement
that's the hardware the 15 minutes is
easy
so bluetooth is used for local
communications and it's good up to maybe
30 meters 100 feet or so depending on
the environment
so can it be used for ranging can you
measure the the six foot
distance accurately uh even if your
devices communicate
much you know a fair amount more than
that i mean it's local but local is
local and
local technically for radio and local
technically for the virus or
maybe different things um and so uh
you know as a theoretician i thought
this would be a piece of cake
uh that you know radiation strength
falls off quadratically with distance
and you just measure the received
strength and that would be it that's
the world is in no way that simple um
here's a picture of
two people carrying cell phones uh the
index case on the left and the contacts
or the potential contact with the right
and you want to measure if they're
within six feet of each other and so the
phone on the left is broadcasting these
random values
that we call chirps and the phone on the
right is recording them
and later on if the infected person gets
tested then they can uh
post the charts that they broadcast or
the seeds to generate them
so the question is what was that a close
contact or not
and you can measure the received signal
strength on the
contact's phone this depends on it turns
out an enormous number of variables
starting with the models of the phone i
suppose first the different phones
broadcast at different strengths
uh so the transmitter power is a
function of the model of the phone also
to what what the transmitter power was
set to on that phone
the phone orientation matters these
antenna antenna are not isotropic you
know depends on which way the phone is
oriented so holding it one way versus
holding it another way
can can have a great impact on the
strength of the received signal
whether it's in your pocket or not in
your pocket can matter whether it's
indoors or outdoors
you know indoors you might have signals
bouncing off the ceiling and so on too
so the strength is
stronger outdoors it's less strong maybe
the phones can tell whether they're
indoors or outdoors we should
factor that into the computation those
are questions that are being considered
perhaps one of the more important
questions is you know where is the
person's body relative to their phone
because
these these signals do not go through
water very well and people are just big
bags of water
so uh you know that's that's an issue it
could make you seem like you're much
further away when you're not
if the body's in the way but walls on
the other hand tend not to absorb this
this signal
so you can't tell if two people are
maybe within six feet of each other but
they happen to be on different sides of
a wall or
and there's no way of detecting mask
wearing and other things like that for
example too which
probably should factor into these kinds
of things
so this may be the biggest technical
challenge for bluetooth-based contact
tracing
you know how to measure distance and
because it's such a hard problem uh and
because
there's also a lot of noise uh you know
we put a lot of
work into this so one is the sampling
rate you know the
reception of these signals takes battery
power and
uh you don't want to turn on the
receiver all the time so how do you get
enough samples how do you schedule the
listening
so that you're not draining the battery
too much
uh the lincoln lab folks have put
incredible effort into this
problem there's a nice paper that just
came out by gary hatkey and colleagues
at lincoln lab which gives a lot of the
details now you've got the
here so just search for hotkey on the uh
archive site and you'll find the find
the details but there's you know the
answer is
can you tell well it depends it depends
on what information you have about
the parties the way they're holding
their phones and so on too mostly here's
a couple of robots that are cute that
were used out in lincoln lab
for uh doing some experiments these
robots are turtle bots you can program
them to wander around and
swing around and do a little dance and
there's even a youtube
youtube video set to music that you can
watch them do do their dance
and get within six feet sometimes and so
on so gathering a lot of data
there's a data collection coalition
which collects uh this kind of bluetooth
ranging data
with many parties participating there's
even a nist challenge
contest for applying machine learning
and other technologies to
this too close for too long problem and
there's a website that if you just
google for nist uh
too close for too long challenge you'll
you'll find the data there
so you can download data sets you can
try to your best machine learning
algorithms
and see how well you can do it at
guessing what the real distances are
given the data that's
that's there and you might have a
sequence of data that was received for
because you've got a you know some
periodic sampling going on as
you're gathering the data between on the
receiving phone of what was transmitted
by the sending phone
there's other technologies available
fixed adding fixed beacons not phones
having wearables of various sorts using
ultrasound or ultra wideband instead of
bluetooth but bluetooth is the main
technology we've been looking at
so that's the technical uh one of the
main technical challenges with
implementing this
there's also privacy concerns which i'm
happy to say seem to be
more in hand although it's not totally
enhanced perhaps you know you can have
various principles like no
phone data should leave your phone
without the user consent you don't even
have to download the app it should be
voluntary
if you do download the app you don't
have to turn it on if you do turn it on
you know you can just put it in listen
mode and not upload mode
if you're infected positive you maybe
have discretion as to whether you
upload the data that generated your
chirps or not and
you know when you discover that as a
listener you may have heard in fact the
chirps you know what you do about that
may be discretionary for youtube
so a lot of user consent uh points here
that help uh people be comfortable with
the privacy guaranteed by such an app
and since that nothing leaves the phone
without their consent
also there's no usage of the gps
location in most of these protocols too
gps is as you can imagine very sensitive
from a privacy point of view
and so these apps
measure proximity of one phone to
another but they don't
measure where you are by using gps so
you can say how this phone was
maybe close to some other phone or close
to some phone of an infected person
but it won't say where you were again so
you were which town you weren't even
the phone uh broadcast these changing
pseudo-random chirps so there's no
tracking just by listening to the chirps
and the focus records chirps that is
heard as we talked about
and then you get seeds posted for the
chirps that were broadcast so by the
affected person
so that's a disgrace of discretion uh
the user
may decide they don't want to be
compliant they tested positive but they
don't want to
be a good citizen they don't want to
notify anybody they may have been here
maybe they were near
people that they don't want to reveal or
something like that or you know
it's not even that because it's the
chirps right but they may feel that
they're revealing the people that they
uh were near so the phone
uh of the listeners can match locally
against the posted database of infected
chirp seeds
and uh there's no need for the central
database to store any personal
information there's no
phone ids necessarily or any location
information of course
it's just the chirps and the and the
fact that these are
valid chirps or trip sequences posted by
people who later turned out to be
infected
so once a phone uh
determines that it has heard a chirp by
a person who later
was infected uh they can then
[Music]
be alerted and maybe have a discussion
with a manual contact tracer
be advised they should stay at home
watch for symptoms get tested et cetera
et cetera because they have to be
integrated
into the public health system and that's
one of the key
design points still being worked through
is how to integrate digital contact
tracing with the traditional
manual contact tracing there are some
active attacks that can be played
against these
protocols for example you can listen to
a chirp and then replay it somewhere
else
relay or relay
uh to be played later uh so replay it
play it later or relay
play it somewhere else uh so there are
ways of doing some of that and you have
to think through the consequences of
that
but there are some uh extensions of the
pro basic protocol for dealing with some
of those
but there are some potential privacy
aspects having to deal with those as
well how to integrate with public health
i think the main point to start off with
is what's your goal here the goal is
not to replace manual contact tracing
but to improve and extend it
you're going to make it better you're
not going to not going to get rid of the
manual contact tracing manual contact
racing is very important
for lots of reasons for one thing
contacting
having the contacts talk with a public
health worker allows them to learn about
social services they may need you know
how are they going to feed themselves if
they're quarantined at home
you know what kind of social services
allow them to take care of child care or
something else
there's just lots and lots of ways in
which the
just being alerted by an app on your
phone is not adequate
so i just just what i said so the
digital contact tracing
process should feed into the manual
contact tracing software
and most jurisdictions have some sort of
manual contact tracing software maybe
as simple as an excel spreadsheet that
they're typing stuff into or maybe a
more complicated salesforce kind of
thing or some other product
so the goal here is to have digital
contact tracing make manual contact
tracing
both more complete by finding contacts
that the
person can't remember that person on the
bus say or making it faster because
maybe the alert
allows the contact to call in and be
notified and advise as to what they
should do quicker
so speed and completeness are the two
criteria for success here
to make it work effectively adoption can
be a challenge
people need to download these apps and
install them
and i note that both parties need to be
running this digital contact tracing
service
if i'm in fact if my phone is
broadcasting it doesn't do any good if
your phone doesn't have a capability of
receiving uh
the chirps that my phone is broadcasting
so if we only have a 50 adoption rate
only 50 percent of the phones are
running this kind of service
then only maybe only 25 percent of the
contacts get logged because you know
50 chance that i have it 50 chance you
have the app and so the
product of those two is 25 so uh you
know the fraction of contacts that get
logged this way
may be small if the adoption rate isn't
really fairly high by fairly high you
know 60 70 percent
to help with this uh apple and google
have done a wonderful thing they've
gotten together and
because you know some people are going
to have apple phones some people can
have android phones uh
supported by google and so they've
announced a protocol a common protocol
the uh automatic exposure notification
protocol
aen that's built into the operating
system of both apple and google
um and this allows for interoperability
between
apple phones and google phones the
android phones
um and this is a huge and very welcome
development i should give my thanks here
to apple and google for
for making this happen that's just a
wonderful step forward without that
uh the apps uh don't work well together
and they have issues with battery drain
as well because if it's not built into
the operating system
they tend to go to sleep when they're
not running in foreground mode and so on
so uh apple and google have done a
wonderful step forward here
and that's built into the operating
system apps get developed on top of that
and need to make use of the api that
apple and google provide
nonetheless um people may resist
adoption
adoption of the apps because they they
fear big brother
they may have concerns about privacy
they may misperceive what the privacy
properties are of the app
they may be concerned about the police
somehow making use of this information
or ice or the housing authorities got
too many people living in the house etc
they may have a confusing ui for example
the android at least
one of the early versions of the android
app allows for location services
permission which sounds like it's using
gps
even though it's not so there may be
resistance to uh that
but nonetheless there have been rollouts
of these apps in a number of places most
notably in europe
uh switzerland for example is doing well
germany denmark
and they have uh adoption rates which
are which are going up
uh but they're still tend to be below 50
percent
and um you know they have huge campaigns
with
celebrities saying that we're using this
app and having lots of
people pushing for it it's hard to get
the adoption rate up
that's another challenge that we have
not a technical challenge but a
messaging challenge or
effectiveness then you can ask the
question does digital contact tracing
really help even we got all
those hurdles can we can it save lives
somehow
and some studies with models uh show
that
yes it could help if you had a contact
tracing mobile phone
app it could stop the epidemic if used
by a sufficiently
high proportion of the population this
is a quote from a paper by freddie at
all in science
in may so some of the modeling studies
in it it's
not clear how much weight to give to
these modeling studies because they all
make
assumptions and one doesn't know whether
the assumptions are the right
assumptions or not
in any case we're starting to see real
results now and
in singapore for example they have a
digital contact tracing app that does
reveal new contacts
beyond those found by manual contact
tracing so we're seeing some
positive results happening there and
again it may allow for faster alerts of
duplicate contacts
digital contact tracing is mostly about
finding
people for the new contacts finding
people you don't remember
seeing and so mask wearing may decrease
the amount of public
trans transmission so uh it may decrease
the number of strangers you infect
and therefore decrease the utility of
digital contact tracing so
there's been no studies whatsoever on
that here's a
little diagram that i'd like to put out
to help you get oriented
so this is um it's got made up numbers
but they're sort of plausible numbers i
think depending on
the context in the state of the world of
with amount of infection
so here's a hundred people represented
and divided into three
categories really four categories with
the one outside so 60 of those hundred
have no relevance to this particular
index case that's been
being looked at here of the people that
that index case has
been near maybe five of them there's
five in this little small circle here
have been infected uh manual contact
tracing finds
23 of them uh of which three are
infected
so manual contact racing is fine and
that's a typical number for for manual
contact tracing if i
call up 23 people you find three of them
when they they're tested they turn out
to be
infected and digital contact tracing
finds maybe 33 people of which three are
infected
and the key points here are that digital
contact tracing is discovering
a new contact there's one person in the
person in pink here
uh discovered by digital contact tracing
and that's a benefit
that we didn't have with manual contact
trace that person was not found that
person would be advised
to quarantine and stay stay off the
street
the green section corresponds to people
that are found both by manual contact
racing and digital contact racing
there's 17 of those and they can get
faster notification perhaps if the app
tells them first you know be careful so
to talk to your main contact racing
folks you've been alerted
so what are the legal questions uh i'm
not a lawyer i'm not sure what the best
questions are but to me the
interesting legal questions might be you
know to what extent could law
enforcement access or use
any of this contact tracing information
there's precedent for these kinds of
questions in the manual contact tracing
world
medical information tends to be very
much protected
and access of i'm not sure the legal
questions actually differ that much
once you've got digital contact tracing
it's the same kind of information more
or less
but i think one needs to look at the
details do we need to update the laws in
any way concerning protection and
sharing of medical data
for handling digital contact tracing
data there is this public database where
these chirps get stored you know just
what needs to be
the law regarding those for example
policy questions um an interesting
very interesting one is should the app
used to be made mandatory
can you require that people download and
run
such a digital contact tracing app the
scenario i've been painting here
talks about volunt a very voluntary kind
of situation where everything is
discretionary
even downloading the app is
discretionary but in china uh
cert various kinds of app users have
been made mandatory
and one can imagine the world drifting
in such a direction that jurisdictions
or services or businesses or schools
start demanding that an app be used and
you need to uh
you know well mostly this is even more
for symptom checking kinds of apps where
you're showing that you haven't had a
any symptoms recently but uh because
proximity
detection has got a delay built in it
doesn't until the it's not until the
infected person
um tests positive that you actually get
notified but still you can imagine some
kind of mandatory
uh requirement for various kinds of apps
relating to covet 19.
one of the interesting questions also is
that there's a tension between public
health
and the desires of public health
officials and privacy
this is attention that occurs in the
manual contact tracing
world as well so some of these issues
are not new
but in general more information revealed
to the system
may improve public health results at a
cost of privacy privacy for example you
know if you add
added gps data to your app well maybe
you could
track people better and find out who
they were near better
and stop the disease more quickly so
there's a push
from some folks to say yeah we should
have gps data you'll see some apps come
out that
use gps data i'm not a fan of that
because of privacy reasons
but there's that tension between public
health and privacy over
the use of gps data another question
that's related is
the question of who infected me if
you're notified that you may have been
infected
you may want to find out who it was that
affected you or might have infected you
and met that's a question that comes up
with manual contact tracing as well
and contact tracers tend to be very good
at
not telling the contact who it was that
might have infected them
as a matter of privacy so that's
precedent there but again
there is pressure to develop statistics
about
what the what the graph looks like of
infections and so on too and
so there's there's pressure to try to
get more information out of the system
than
good privacy policy would allow and then
there's a question of who decides on
policy government
or high tech or public health somebody
else right now it's a very interesting
situation with google and apple
having set some privacy
limits on what these apps can do they
provide an api
which if you use it comes with
restrictions you can't use it build an
app on top of that api
that gathers gps information for for
example
you can only use an app that's approved
by a public health authority
and you have to follow a bunch of other
rules so there's there's policy
um being said privacy policy being set
by
apple and google i tend to like the
decisions they made but
it is being set by these companies
rather than by
say a government uh authority or public
health
authority something and google and apple
tend to be very strong on the privacy
side of things here but it's
it's their decisions as to what it takes
to get an app approved to be sold in one
of their stores
and then there's a question as to you
know does this app get turned off when
the pandemic is over
there's going to be another pandemic
after this one maybe you should have the
pandemic just loaded in ready to go
maybe should just be turned off maybe
just the data should be erased and what
are the policies for
what happens when the pandemic is over
assuming it's over and this could be
chronic if we're not careful but you
know so we
repeat it somehow so in conclusions
we've come a long way
since covet 19 appeared we've got
decentralized privacy preserving
protocols we've got a much better stand
understanding of bluetooth phenomenology
although it's
not yet working as well as i naively
expected at the beginning
we've got google and apple collaborating
on a api to support notification
uh yeah there's still lots of challenges
including the technical ones of ranging
there's dealing with the fragmented
nature of u.s health care many many
states many jurisdictions
and so you can imagine many many
different apps being rolled out in the
us at different places
and achieving sufficient adoption rates
is going to be one of the big challenges
for these apps as well
but there's lots of legal and privacy
issues too as i mentioned and i look
forward to
questions and that's really what i
wanted to say i hope that's
stimulating and i look forward to the
questions later
thanks ron um and i think that we are
now going to uh
pass the batoon to helen helen are you
there
i'm here okay hi
oops sorry yes i'll just take a moment
to set myself
up and i'll share screen
with for my
and after you there will be a q a which
uh
a sec all right turn on
i have to do things in the right order
and
is that does that work
perfect it's good
hi everybody uh and thanks to the
organizers for
including me in this event uh first of
all thank you
ron for
like one of the best if not the best
discussion and description of digital
contact tracing that i've
ever heard and i've been a bit obsessed
with it and
going and bothering people to explain
how everything
works and reading and and watching
webinars and
your talk was incredible and my main
failure here is going to be to try and
remember everything you said and make
sure that it's relevant to the comments
i'm making and of course
i look forward to challenges and
questions
so um as some of you know i'm a
philosopher and
i have been thinking about technology
and ethics for
many years um what i wanted to do is a
little bit of a teaser because
uh the issues of values in design which
i'm going to
or values at play are quite relevant as
a methodology and so
while i'm going to come to the issue of
contact
tracing i also want to cheat a little
bit
and introduce some of some of the
theory of values in design
and as many of you know there's a
complicated
relationship sorry
between society and societal values on
the one hand
and technology high tech
and in our case we're thinking about
digital technology on the other hand
and over many decades they've been
philosophers social scientists
lawyers social critics who've been
talking about technology and society
technology and societal values
sometimes they stand on the outside and
they look in as technology is something
different
um taking an external perspective but
the work that i've been doing and i want
to say
an emergent well it's been slowly
emerging and
sometimes very much in the shadows is a
school of thought
or a way of seeing technology through
the lens of societal values that
actually seeks collaboration
and considers it impossible to talk
about
ethical and and political values
embedded in technologies or the impacts
of technology on society
without working hand in hand and without
collaborating
with the the scientists and engineers
of um computing and digital technology
so it's very much a hope of working in
partnership with the technologists
and the general frame framing of this
idea
is values in design where it adopts
the position that ethical and political
values can be actually embedded
in digital technology and one version of
this or one
framework that adopts this uh starting
position is
values at play and that's the one i'm
going to briefly describe to you
and then move to the question of contact
tracing
and it assumes that you um it's useful
for two things
one is to take into consideration
existing technologies and tries to
analyze or read values
into those technologies and the other
one is to
suggest that technologists conscientious
technologists
who are interested can take ethical and
political values into consideration
when they design and develop
technologies
and this framework values a play
suggests a collaborative approach to
doing this
so the values that play framework
involves three components there are
there aren't steps so it's not
first second third but it's just three
activities that
uh look um different from one another
and
uh we've labeled them and i should
mention two key collaborators on this on
mary flanagan who's a games designer
um and a digital artist and
daniel howe who is a systems designer
protester his faculty in hong kong mary
flanagan at dartmouth
so there are three components in values
at play
one is discovery and this
another one is implementation and the
third is verification
so when we look at discovery there are
two activities that are part of
discovery one is the specification
the the one subpart is specification of
functional goals and values
when you're developing or analyzing a
technology you think about
what's it for and included in the what's
on
what's it for can be values you can
constrain
the way you develop the technology
technology according to values so
you know the discussion of facial
recognition we say yes we wanted to be
effective
but we also wanted not to unfairly
discriminate
against certain subgroups
and you have then as
actually deidre had commented once
you've established or understood or
listed the values you're interested in
you need to define the have a good sense
of what your definition is
the uh the conceptual clarity the values
the definition of the values concepts
that you're interested in
implementation is when you have these
values and goals that you're interested
in
you're worrying about how do you
operationalize
into the design of the system
architecture mechanisms features and so
forth
and for example
with the tsa who want to develop
software for scanning bodies as they
about to board planes
we want to have some kind of image that
reveals
the the potential weapons that a person
might have or in their luggage
but at the same time sometimes you may
have values that conflict with one
another
and in the tsa case it may be modesty or
privacy
or other values and you need to
think about how do you address how do
you resolve conflicts in technology
and what we offer in values at play is
that sometimes
if you're inventive in your design you
can actually get both you can dissolve
the conflict
sometimes you can't and you have to
compromise and finally
you would need to trade off finally the
the third component is verification
which is you know did it do what you
wanted to do and i'm not going to spend
any more time on it
so this is the summary discovery
implementation and that
verification now we come to the question
of contact tracing
and i was i was so happy ron that you
[Music]
listed you know for us manual contact
tracing because
it it finally things clipped into place
when
i started looking at the automated
digital tools
and had to check them back against
the traditional contact tracing what
were the functions
that we were seeking and what were the
values so
some that i've heard people talk about
that i think are important
individual health you know how can it
help individuals
who are exposed or who are test positive
what kind of clinical learning can we
take away or scientific learning
what about population health how how do
they
affect our epidemiological models of
transmission how come the cdc
is saying you know less than six feet
greater than 15 minutes how did they
come up with that
that's the kind of thing you can learn
from and you can keep
updating your models as well at the same
time as you mentioned
privacy is really important social
justice autonomy and so forth
and so the question is what should your
digital tools be
in order to achieve these functions and
also be
consistent with societal values
now some of you i'm going to focus on
privacy
and show how the conceptual definition
actually affects the shape of the
technical system so
many of you know privacy is contextual
integrity
doesn't agree that privacy is about
control of information
rather it's about the appropriate flow
of information conforms with legitimate
contextual
and in this case health norms and i use
the word rules because i realize
computer scientists got so confused when
i
used the word norms and
legitimate norms are those that promote
stakeholder interests
and contextual in this way uh in this
case
um health domain functions and values
now i hope i mean this is this is many
books and many articles condensed into a
single slide but
hopefully some of it will become evident
this is my final slide
definitely not going to be able to get
through everything
and i've actually lost track of how much
time
i've been using up so
here's where i slightly part company
with ron if we adopt a definition
of privacy as contextual integrity
then it may be okay
to mandate the tech the use of the
technology by a legitimate authority
and i mean heavens knows whether such an
authority exists
even in government because you know
we're living in strange times but
ideally you would need to mandate
otherwise the efficacy
is just too low and
what's the use of it if 10 percent or 15
of people are utilizing the app
or you know on top of the apis
um then the flow of the covert status is
is it is determined not by consent
but by individual and societal health
needs
the exposure and further infection data
flows that is to say
if you were exposed and then you were
later
found to be positive what information
is shared and i think again this
question like
gps um who the
person is and so forth to whom for what
and under what constraints
and then um who receives the information
uh is that legitimate authorities
and um here i think i also
am concerned about the the gapple or the
google apple api which does restrict the
continuation of the flow
to back to the public authority because
and here i'm pointing to that where the
arrow is
on the slide how do you improve your
epidemiological
models of transmission
if you don't insist that the information
of both
exposure and then coming down
with the virus are cycled back
to the public health authority um
and then i go through the different the
other like
competing definitions of privacy is
control where subjects
choose to install subjects choose
what and whether and with whom covert
status is shared
those exposed choose whether and with
whom to shake
the exposure and later infection
infection
status and the argument here is that
there's not
a trade-off there's no conflict because
once we decide what the appropriate flow
is
and that is based on what it is that
we need to achieve with
these apps and apis
then we the most important thing
we need to achieve as a policy matter is
to restrict
the recipient of the information to be
very transparent
and and very clear about what the
recipients of the information
can do with the information
and that's it thank you
thank you uh helen um
so i actually uh so so now uh it's gonna
be a q a
but i must say that i have the first
question what is it that you disagree
with ron about
i didn't understand exactly um
my disagreement with ron um ron
assumes privacy broadly believe ron
asserts that privacy is is control over
information
about yourself and so
you set privacy up as antagonistic
towards some of the needs
that the health authority or the public
health
has in order to achieve
what contact tracing
[Music]
manual contact tracing and automated
contact tracing um should contribute
if you consider privacy so then you set
it up as
privacy versus whatever
else the need is got it
uh so i don't know ron if you want to
respond sure um yeah
i think that's an accurate perception of
what i said i think my
views are probably larger than what i
said in some sense too i think
one of the concerns that people have is
that privacy is
uh to be evaluated not just as
designed and hopefully implemented
following that design
but is the system subject to abuse and
in particular is the subject
subject to abuse in a way that could
abuse people's
privacy so that you know for example
should uh
the government change or in a way that
would be
indifferent to people's privacy could
they take a system like this and
change its uh implementation or change
its usage
in a way that would cause people's
privacy to be abused so there's privacy
risks
not just for the design as proposed
which
is fine as it may actually be used or
rather abused
in practice and so i think one of the
concerns the technologists have is to
design a system
that can't be abused and this may limit
the kinds of uh
epidemiological utility that uh ellen
was talking about
um there is a real trade out there i
mean the the tension between
epidemiological needs and perceived
privacy needs is a real one and they
should be discussed i think that
it could i wonder it's possible that the
only disagreement we have is
one how we use our words because the way
i would frame it is to say
we have this epidemiological need which
um where the models just focusing on
that for the moment
where the models can be improved when
you have feedback
you know maybe you were less than six
feet you were five feet and
so on and then you know ten days later
you
you test positive for covert now unless
we have a lot of this information
going back to the public health
authority in order to perform the
analysis
we're going to miss out on even
improvements that may be correct
let me let me respond i see where you're
going with that if i can engage in some
dialogue here
you know we don't have digital contact
tracing as the only source of
information though i think these systems
are all
intended to be fielded in a context
where digital contact tracing is working
alongside of manual contact tracing
and i haven't seen any argument that
says that manual contact tracing can't
provide adequate statistics
to inform the development of appropriate
epidemiological models
so i think
i like that image of the digital contact
tracing or exposure notification if we
want to be more precise
working within a larger manual contact
racing environment the main thing
i want to do is preserve the use of the
word privacy
so it's true that information can be
exploited information can be abused
and so on so the most important thing
that we
all want to do in the name of privacy is
to ensure
that the information flows in an
appropriate way
and that is according to the ends and
purposes
not according to whether individuals
consent or not
so i think like just
to be clear my thoughts on
implementing privacy are not only
oriented towards individual discretion
which is what i emphasize in my talk
certainly because i do feel that's very
important
but there's also privacy controls from
the beginning and the design of the
system
so google and apple in particular don't
allow an app
to have gps information for example
which would be useful and very useful
for
some of the epidemiological needs
looking for super spreading events and
so on
so there are technical means that are
not individual discretion
but but choices made at the design time
which allow
control information flow and and so i
think those are
maybe the more important ones in some
way well at least as important
uh for trying to assess some of these
questions so there's both design level
decisions
and then operational decisions made by
the parties in the middle of the
implemented design uh i'd like to open
the
the floor to other questions are there
people just unmute themselves and speak
we will do it this way
i will uh can i take the floor michael
is that okay so uh hi everybody it's
wonderful to see so many familiar
friends and faces here
and a couple of questions please for ron
and helen
uh it seems uh that the concern
about the location gps
based apps uh other than
you know whether they are effective or
not which is obviously important
from the privacy point of view is the
government the state
and uh there are other aspects of
privacy kind of
many people are concerned of their data
being collected by
the cell companies the mobile service
providers
and of course google and apple so
that is another concern which
i'm not sure i heard enough of now maybe
there are
good technological ways to deal with
that with encryption and whatever
anonymization if it's possible
so i was wondering about that and to
helen uh
so uh there's there's much i like about
contextual integrity but i do have my
critique as you know
and i was wondering in this context
why is this only a health context
because the data
emanates or is created in the context of
a commercial setting in which i
pay for you know for the mobile service
provider
and some of the data is created by me
just using it in my daily life
so that's one context which becomes a
health context
there are two contexts here that merge
and also there's the social context
because if the data collected is about
proximity of people
even if it's encrypted etc assuming some
smart guys like some of you in this room
can find ways to re-identify
people and hence contacts and
that might expose you know whom am
i in relation to you know
who do i see etc not only the stranger
that happened to
sit next to me on the bus or whatever
and so i would argue that there are at
least three contexts here
the commercial of us using the phone the
social
us and other people and then it becomes
a health context and what i've
heard the subtext or you know in my ears
some sort of balancing that you
conduct with as you define
the transmission the informational
transmission rules of the health context
but it's a mixture of contexts
and just to add to that and but with
that i will conclude uh
resistance uh in israel uh there are
many people who say
that they stopped carrying their cell
phones with them
and we have some sort of you know
security surveillance
going on and some other things but
people
want to avoid being being
misidentified in various places so they
just
don't carry their phones with them which
is not very helpful
in managing the pandemic thank you
sorry maybe i could respond to the
first earlier part of your questions
there you were talking about
protection privacy concerns with respect
to say apple and google too
i think as a rule cryptographers tend to
be
professionally the most paranoid uh
people that i've met
right they are used to thinking about
all the ways that things could go wrong
and what happens if uh this party or
that party or this collection of parties
should be bad actors or colluding with
each other and so on too so so these are
kinds of scenarios that cryptographers
do think about daily and it's the kind
of thing that informs what's happening
here
so in particular to your question you
know what happens if apple is a bad
actor or google is a bad actor those are
the kinds of things that are
explicitly considered in the design of
these protocols and apple and google do
not in their databases or the design of
the
protocols put themselves in a position
where they are in any way privileged
with respect to personal information
they can't identify people they can't
find out where people are or or you know
who's been talking to whom
these are anonymized you know random
identifiers so the questions you're
asking are good ones
but i think that to the extent possible
like the cryptographic design of these
protocols
protects uh privacy as at least the
cryptographers understand it
by abuse by the parties involved to a
large extent there are some active
attacks where people try to
you know for example let me mention one
that's interesting that i think uh may
need to be addressed in the future
version of this
you know somebody could go into a
doctor's office where people are about
to be tested
they could listen to all of the chirps
of their phones and then go somewhere
else to a subway station
and rebroadcast those chirps for other
people to hear and then when the person
tests positive
that was in the doctor's office those
other people the subway station think
well they might have been exposed
you know so that's not a privacy concern
maybe but it's
a operational concern so there's those
kinds of attacks where you
people think about active attacks so um
so i think
the concerns arrays are good ones but i
think
these protocols to the extent they can
be addressed by protocol
design tend to be pretty well handled by
these protocols the protocol level
the privacy protection level is in fact
the least of my concerns about all this
digital content tracing stuff
i worry more about i lose sleep over
other aspects of like such as
measuring distance or adoption rates and
so on too those are the the harder ones
uh i think we can hide privacy ones
pretty
what is the notion of privacy here for
instance if
if uh if my interaction network is very
sparse
i interact with one person and i get a
notification that one of the chirps is
positive
and now i learned that this person is
yeah so
i think that the useful definition and
it's the kind of definition we see a lot
in cryptography
is that you know the digital contact
tracing privacy standards
should model the manual contact tracing
standards
so you have exactly the same issues with
manual contactors if you get a call from
a contact tracer saying
you might have been exposed and you know
that you've only been in
the presence of one person over the last
two weeks well you know who you might
have been exposed by
so it's exactly the same i think that
fundamentally i
i have a problem with that answer
because
um maybe i want to keep open the
question of whether
you inform the person who it was or
where it was
that that they were exposed if you think
about the goal
of contact racing or even if you think
about different diseases
like think about sexually transmitted
disease where
contact tracing has been a very
important tool
you if you actually want to intervene in
the spread of the disease
then actually you you may want to give
the exposed party
more information about who they were
exposed to
um i also i don't know i don't i mean
the time
it would take to properly respond to
michael is is more than we have
but i just wanted to talk about the
commercial
situation and i have been concerned
about privacy in relation to google and
apple with mobile devices because i
think that we're very vulnerable
and so i i sort of hoped like maybe this
is a moment in which people will pay
attention to
how much leakage there is to google and
apple and i
i tend to maybe have less trust
because because i think there's a lot of
exploitation
of data by those companies so yes there
is that different context and yes we
need to
um make those determination about what
prevails
and maybe ask ron this question about
the database
whether it's a matter of impossible
technical
impossibility for apple and google
to use the key that i believe they're
generating
to reconnect the phone identities with
the information that's in the databases
or is it just a matter of policy
that they say we're not going to do that
um so you are as a phone owner you would
be trusting apple and google to
implement
the design as published uh which doesn't
i mean once
once you've got a phone a device made by
somebody else you know if that party is
a bad actor
they can they can turn on the microphone
they can turn on the camera in ways you
don't know
whatever they can do all kinds of ways
of invading your privacy so you are
trusting
uh the manufacturer of that phone and
the software on that phone
to uh honestly implement the designs
that that you think they're implementing
uh that's
you know that said i mean this
particular protocol if design if
implemented according to the design
is not one that gives apple and google
any uh particular
advantage or privilege with respect to
identifying people or their contacts
uh it's a very narrow protocol it uses
these randomized identifiers
uh there's no way that i can see how
they could make use of the database
information the database
to de-identify people um without
other information and if you start
putting in other information
you know maybe there could be something
if you have somebody tracking somebody
and following them around
you know that there's there's a lot of
information coming into play there i'm
not sure that
it's been carefully studied but i don't
see how the digital contact tracing
would add any uh
advantage to somebody trying to do that
kind of tracking of somebody
but these are worth looking at it's
they're carefully designed and these
identifiers change rapidly so i don't
think there's much leverage that anybody
gets by
trying to fool around with the database
or listening to just these random chirps
without doing something active so um
it's 10 o'clock
and uh i just wanted to say something
about the topic but then
we will separate we'll have a break for
15 minutes and then we come back we'll
be separated into groups
where we have some different topics uh
privacy challenges public private
interface
voluntary versus mandatory aspects and
transparency and accountability
but i just want to say something that so
in some sense um
ron and i think uh a natural uh
approach by a cryptographer so take the
extreme privacy
perspective where ellen you're bringing
up issues that obviously we all
realize are important but they are
difficult to define
like what is it that you are willing to
uh
release and then how would you
cryptographically match that i just want
to mention that there is a whole
framework of how to define these things
also within cryptography
which we call sort of uh ideal versus
real so if
you had a formula formulation what the
ideal world would be
that is how much information you want to
give and and uh
and nothing but okay and then there's
sort of a definition of how would you
match that in a real world by protocol
and then you
we also have methods of proving that
what you have actually matches that
um but it starts with actually
formulating what it is
the ideal world uh you want to provide
and that is
you know i think that we often run into
a problem that when we are
dealing with a real situation okay that
people who are
uh advocating for
giving more uh releasing more facts and
or uh don't formulate it
so if they did if they were able to we
often could match it by technical means
all right anyway so a break you can go
have coffee or whatever it is you do
lunch depending on your time zone you
know can i ask a quick question the
chat stuff that's on the side or i mean
on my side
is someone um is that also recorded
because it's so useful but
i haven't been able to monitor it
um yes i mean i don't know
yes i assume so i can i can keep that
yeah i'll keep it recording okay great
at least in mind if you click the three
dots at the lower right it says save
chat you can save the uh
cool oh oh cool sure where that gets
saved exactly or
how you get that access to it okay
this is from ron okay in any case i feel
much better now
so in 15 minutes uh don't be late
uh it'll be interesting bye